the daily beast
viper merrick garland's trump raid
is only the first inning okay democratic
strategist named james carville has a
message for people who are doubting
merrick garland just wait people are
like well but let's wait and see a
little bit and this is like the top of
the first inning i mean remember merrick
garland is like a pit viper he
prosecuted the oklahoma city bomber case
the unabomber case the olympic bomber
case and i think these guys are really
methodical trump and the mega
republicans defenses are just literally
absurd i mean absurd like he can
declassify anything he wants says
carville plus you ask why did trump want
all these documents and the answer is
the most logical reason he was going to
sell them right because he needs money
right
what a ridiculous thing to say but
you're talking about a guy that some
call him the democratic strategist you
know this is like the
brain that comes up with strategies this
is not just a
lightweight pundit from cnn or msnbc
saying something like this well you know
a lot of
former presidents have kept lots of
documents
uh you know obama it's in the millions
of documents
why do they keep them
well you know not everybody gets to be
president i mean this is kind of cool to
have these documents
uh save them for prosperity save them
for your library which will eventually
be built um
i don't think it necessarily
means that you have nefarious purposes
do you agree with them that this is just
the top of the first inning or is this
one of those things where adam schiff
got up and hey it's i know for a fact
there was a russia collusion like how do
you well i think because there's been so
much pushback
uh
they probably are gonna
not be as aggressive
as they might have been before why too
much push right so so some people say
some people will say that you'll talk to
a democrat and democrats will say
uh
well let me tell you this has got
nothing to do with election no one on
the left is afraid of
trump running for office that's
ludicrous he doesn't have that kind of
credibility anymore he lost it all you
know the left is not afraid of him
running again okay fine that's their
argument that's their wishful thinking
they don't want to see them run again
why don't they
because i mean look at the crowds that
come out and see him look at the
enthusiasm behind
that kind of
activity
you you don't want somebody who's going
to rally the troops
you want sort of a sleeper candidate
so yeah they would do everything they
can to make sure that he doesn't run
again
and that's why they're going to try to
find a way to indict him
because i don't think while you're under
indictment that you can run from
president so if you like this clip and
you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
[Music]